we might be drunk
we
might be drunk
as long as we are hanging out you know
we might be drunk raise a glass let's
talk [ __ ] pet peeves wrecks and a bit
maybe drunk
we might be drunk
yeah
yo hey
here we are we're started up we might be
drunk good to be back i haven't seen you
all week it's been a week yeah yeah we
both went to our respected
gigs and then come back and you did and
you did it you taped the special oh yeah
forgot all about it tell me about it it
was great covered guidelines you take
the special corporate guidelines are
tough for that you know sam black the
audience legendary audience warm-up or
what do you call cedar she's an audience
coordinator coordinator she's a legend
because one time she's so intimidating
our best friend is comics because
she makes sure the house is packed yep
she makes sure people know how to behave
in the show yeah but one time apparently
i think it was during an anthony
jeselnik tape you know someone might
have been jeslenik
they were so scared of her that they
peed their pants
yeah they were like i don't want to mess
up the taping and she gets people so in
line why because someone pissed
themselves oh my god so she's my gal
she's on our side
geez louise that's that's wild yeah yeah
she is brassy she is a breast she's a
real new yorker
is she yeah i i brought it up she's from
like the cayman islands and the cats but
she's been here forever it's been here
forever yeah she banged uh what's his
face oh like what are you talking about
no it's a joke what's that guy's name
walk on the wild side
who's more of a new yorker i think
you're giving real gossip
no no i'm just saying she seems like
somebody was like i was hanging out with
warhol and all that yeah in the factory
yes but uh either way i got to i love
her she's so cool she's got so many
stories and we got to chatting and uh
she said this might be the last because
delta was kicking up so it might be the
last unmasked performance
in a while and i was like jesus she's
like we just slid right in we're lucky
to be here i was like oh man that's what
lou reed said to her
there we go there was one lady's whole
job was to go
to tell you to pick up the mask
that was her whole job so what do you
mean they'd pick up the mask for like if
you're backstage and the mask is down
here should go
to you or to everybody everybody
everybody
crew tablets your sucks i know i hate it
i thought we were coming out of it but
everything else aside from code was
gangbusters uh without a hitch i saw
taylor we hung out brian simpson and i
are our fast friends we made love he's
great i never
well
anally i don't know if that counts but
he's a great guy and a great comic yeah
i i've seen the clips uh he did a clip
on uh
on david spade's show back in the day
yeah i think i sent it to you yeah you
did yeah it was killer killer about how
racism is like pennies that's there but
no one no one talks about it or
something i can't i'm butchering it but
smart smart stuff uh
but yeah great we got i think we got in
the can on the first one and then the
second one i got lucy goosey
yeah to the point where my reps were
like
easy out there
what do you mean well i had a thing in
my throat and i did a whole like oh i
did the semen you know i swallowed a
load it was a huge load he was samoan i
went off on like a tangent about the
jizz and it was killing so they were the
crew was like well you got to keep that
in i'm like i don't know it's filthy
they're like keep that we were dying so
that's always nice
but it's fun
i know it is crazy that you used to be
so nervous yeah these things and they're
just like i got jizz in my throat and
people like jesus i know i know yeah but
it's cool seeing like we got
you know [ __ ] podcast fans in the
front row people are going out
you had your people there oh yeah the
drunks were there the gays were there it
was uh it was a hot night and there was
a couple people who never heard me
obviously and they were like
yeah i went dark i went all in i heard
you in dark so yeah give me an example
you know like i just hit all the hot
button anals in the trans the blm the
the the everything you know i went all
in
men women gay black white did you get
pushback
no not really i couldn't say [ __ ] that
was the big push but then brian simpson
said it but
he threw it in with the n-word so it's
kind of in the mix so you could really
yeah it's like putting pill in food
right there yes yeah exactly and when i
said the n-word uh it was tough to
swallow as well but what are we drinking
uh today we're doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a classic cocktail from detroit
from the 20s oh wow yeah it's nice and
it's um
it's from detroit in the 20s yeah okay
uh yeah what's the history
so the history is that it was at the
detroit athletic club that someone made
it up and it was made from their um own
like bathtub gin
it was like you know the gin was really
rough so they have to dress it up with a
lot of things wow so this is uh once
again like the paper plane uh
like all equal parts uh but it's three
quarter ounces ounces i know i neglected
to mention that last time but it's three
quarter ounces uh you can take it on a
plane
so you could take it on a plane exactly
uh it's three-quarter ounces gin
three-quarter ounces green chartreuse
and uh three-quarter ounce lime and
luxardo maraschino damn
i see you got your math checked out by
the way the other comments kicked you
right in the fanny on the uh algebra
there
on the fractions they really gave them
the business
yeah they're like three four three four
three four this guy knows how to add huh
well it just sounds that's it yeah
they're cruel out there but you know we
appreciate it you know loves bathtub gin
whitney houston
[Music]
i was on the road the night she died i
remember the night she died i was in
knoxville
uh tennessee opening for a comedian who
passed away recently spanky brown what
do you know spanky bro no that sounds
made up no well it's he was
so i remember that night because it was
the night jeremy lin dropped 38 on the
lakers insanity so i remember i this is
the tweet i remember from that and i
forgot who said it but someone tweets
holy [ __ ] whitney houston died that's
insane
christ twitter man man did he have a run
the the city was abuzz with insanity
speaking of buzz
cheers cheers
thank you beard my doctor he told me to
watch my drinking now i drink in front
of a mirror all right
he ran my blood he opened up a dab i'll
tell you
now gin might be the least desirable
alcohol you think so i think so it
depends i know people who drink gin and
soda drink gin straight i think ricky
velez drinks gin gin tonic damn that is
amazing that's a good drink
that's a summertime drink right there
yeah dude
oh boy oh boy
that is delightful thank you good man
danny it's called what is it called it's
called the last word the last word
i like yeah
that's good stuff yeah i was in kentucky
all weekend uh this feels like a
kentucky on your front porch yes
i'll tell you man that city i'd run on
hershberg open for me if you don't know
his comedy check him out
r-a-a-n-a-n hershberg
dude killer dude
he's got high energy and great jokes
he's a hard follower he's
loud he's brash he's funny he's smart
and he's high energy like he's sweating
up there oh he got off one time one
night and he was sweaty and i was like
oh you work way harder than i do up here
i'm literally leaning against the stool
i respect that i mean for sure it's it's
another testament this is a horrible
timing but uh
i met him when he was boozing like 20
years ago and uh he was uh he was a son
of an onion like he was an old drunken
sailor like he was
cantankerous
yeah you can get that out he was yeah
and he i remember that's why i met him
in cincinnati go bananas uh
and
he had an edge he did definitely she was
smoking cigarettes he was boozing he was
like a angry little poet yeah he was he
was he was like a little tiny jewish
hemingway
and uh but still funny back then then
cut off the sauce and now he's just
just a happier dude happier dude funny
as hell killing i feel like he's got
some credits and uh he's at the cellar
he's he's gonna be big i think he opens
for whitney every now and then yeah you
whitney the other guy
not bad
this is unreal dan he's good killer
you're a really
cockyologist tough much this is
delightful
i'll tell you it's like one of those
kills he would kill so hard in front of
me i would have to open with local stuff
just to get them that's the move because
i don't have that energy i just i'm not
gonna yell i'm not gonna so i had to i
had some kentucky bits from the last
time i was there my opener was uh
because i went to the racetrack
you know yes i was the worst dressed
person there was the only one who didn't
look like a villain and django unchained
so i opened with that that saved me a
little just some horse racing jokes yep
got him but damn i i was sweating for
the first couple minutes for sure yeah i
wasn't moving i was sweating because i
was like [ __ ] he's killed he kills but
it's a testament to the writing because
you have to come up there and you're not
gonna tap dance it's just gonna be on
the basis of the jokes well he's got the
jokes and the energy that's true that's
true he's gonna pass all of us let's be
honest
and he's not drinking uh we're ruined
yeah this is the problem with this dad
is it's too good you gotta suck them
down like
really good only three quarter rounds
jen so you'll be all right
if only whitney was in a tub that late
i'll tell you
i'll tell you a good teacher really
seems to good
i can't so that's my new drinking i have
like a i have like tourette's
karate rats can you uh
what what do you think about the guys
who wake up with the the bathtub with
the ice you know they're like [ __ ] my
spleen is gone you ever hear about that
is that a myth no i think that i think
it's their kidney not their spirit oh
they're kidding me that's right well
they uh i mean it's funny the ice bath
it's either that or uh you had a great
workout yeah you're like an athlete yeah
yeah
you're either joe rogan or you just got
left in a motel six right you got
shanghai or whatever
i did a gig in portland once a day i
took the shanghai tour you know what
that is
shanghai is where you're at a bar
somebody knocks you out with a blunt
object and you wake up on a fishing boat
in the middle of tahiti or whatever and
they go yeah get to work
shanghai you got shanghai i didn't i'm
just saying i did the shanghai tour
where they they tell you what happened
damn that was a big because portland's a
big port town obviously and uh they
throw you on a fishing boat with a bunch
of like mongolians and you're that's it
i'm going to be there soon oh well keep
a head on a swivel you've been knocked
out of the bar before i have i wasn't
knocked out i was just hit twice so i've
been hit in the face in a bar damn yeah
thank god with the jew helmet fro did
you fro save me yeah
it's padding it's crazy it is padding i
had longer hair it was one of the things
where i needed a haircut and i just
didn't get a haircut and i had that my
mom was so mad at me because she
followed me on instagram and i was
posting like insta stories with the cops
making jokes about it i'd still shards
of glass in my hair but i was like what
am i going to do i'm like i need i can
plug these gigs i'll do something and
the cops are rolling their eyes but i'm
like hey you better get this guy officer
and they're just like all right and my
mom's like what she called me what the
[ __ ] happened i'm like i'm sorry damn
well i know about that was vermont yeah
what was the other one the other one i
was uh
i do it's part of this white knight
story when i do that but it's just i
gloss over quickly but i was uh i was in
a bar in seattle with
uh a comic andrew rivers oh he's funny i
like yeah yeah he's funny and we were
together after shows years ago and
this woman just kept insulting me to the
point where i just finally like i was
talking to a friend she kept being like
she could do a bit better she could do
it like and i was just like uh well i
said why don't you get some more botox
she lizard that's right i should have
said that i don't feel good about saying
that that's what i said and uh
her boyfriend just decks me whoa pretty
good he's a big guy too and i was like
it was one of those things where he got
a pretty clean shot at me and he's a big
dude and i was okay and i was kind of
like
whoa
that's it maybe you got a good job i
don't think i do i think i think i got
lucky like maybe i don't know what
happened but uh where'd he get you the
cheek like right here oh that's great he
got me pretty good pretty much i
remember i did this and i did the whole
like i did
and i was like whoa that was pretty cool
yeah and then uh the bartender handed me
i got broken up pretty quickly some guy
stepped in oh wow and i was drunk so i
just like was like walking closer like
that but uh
bro
broken up yeah it is kind of badass to
get hit and not go down that is glad
about that he hit me and i just did that
[ __ ] and uh i bet she brings that up in
five years she's like you're not a real
man he's like [ __ ] you i always stand up
and he's like when you hit that jew he
didn't fall
he's like [ __ ] you you know that haunts
me you couldn't even knock down that
lanky [ __ ] you're not a man ah that's
like your [ __ ] get out i mean you got a
good tail going like you got like you
got hitting up with a bottle or was it a
glass or a bottle a pint glass he took a
pint glass so his hand was pretty badly
cut too because he just did push right
over
because you just don't expect people to
do that i know you can't fight you got a
good rep going so far like that's two
major hits and you you stayed stayed
strong i'm telling you you gotta we got
a legacy
i just didn't collapse he didn't
collapse but i think most people get i
got hit with a um
a bottle once uh in college this guy hit
me at a fraternity party hit me with and
it went it shattered so good that it
just didn't hurt that bad because just
shattered immediately if it shatters
it's better yeah you look good you look
good so
and i had blood i was like jesus and the
blood went like that like apocalypse now
and i was like who wants some and they
were like no no no but i was terrified
but i had the blood coming down so
everybody's like ah you're good man he's
crazy dude yeah he's [ __ ] crazy
he became a legend that night yeah yeah
it was a foam party so i was home party
remember those no oh maybe that was a
southern thing you'd run a warehouse and
you'd buy a big foam machine it would
just blow bubbles and then like women
would go in with bikinis and every guy
had a boner and it was just like this
bubble
[ __ ] fest it was amazing i wonder
remember ice luges oh yeah i wonder if
those are dead because of covet oh
that's right
i love those yeah they get so cold and
whenever you see when you're like this
is going to be a rager you're drinking
poison
you're good poison but if it's on ice it
feels classy yeah you know it's that big
block somebody to buy that thing and
then you gotta like you're like well the
clock's ticking that thing's gonna melt
so we got to do a lot of shots oh yeah
yeah
yeah man the fight thing i didn't even
do [ __ ] the vermont one i did nothing
honestly like the guy was just talking
[ __ ] and i made like a sarcastic comment
back and i took a [ __ ]
glass of the head
carmen lagala
uh i really really it's like you really
realize who you are as you get older and
you're like well i'm not a fighter but
i'll get a good line in before more
important i would think
one of my favorite lines you guys uh
they they arrested me for being drunk in
public i was in a bar they threw me into
public
that's
arrest
great bit man he's good he has some
stories where you're like that is
like that whole album uh
drunk in public is like it's another
killer and just the delivery is so
different it's so old-school with the
cigar he has the cigar into his contract
so he can even if it's a non-smoking
building he's allowed to smoke damn yeah
and he just holds a
i guess tequila or whiskey and a cigar
and just stands there and delivers that
takes years to perfect people don't
realize that like that guy is like a
real orator
yeah man i remember that book i killed
there's road stories about all those
comics and his was the guy gave him a
bad review
and he just sent the guy a little pint
of whiskey and a razor blade and the
note just said just in case you're ever
in the mood
[Laughter]
you've heard that fitzsimmons story he
got booked to do a college in iowa or
some idaho some like super
hillbilly kind of corn town and they
said be clean
he goes filthy
bombs oh no he kills because he goes
filthy they said that was an immoral act
you you should be ashamed of yourself it
was against god they wrote a whole
letter they didn't pay him whoa and then
like
years later he won an emmy or some i'm
butchering the story but he wanted emmy
or something big and he had the thing
framed and sent it back to him oh no he
told us that he read that thing on stage
at the emmys the letter or something oh
but pull it up man either way
he wins either way he sent it back to
him and was like yeah i was still still
immoral i don't know it was great i love
when the good guy was it's all [ __ ]
like when you're doing a corporate gig
and they're like that joke's offensive
and you're like i did it on fallon i
know
i did it on the squeakiest clean late
night show i know yeah i had a good
moment the other day i was doing a set
and i had the lady in the front row
going ah
you know like that thing you know like
that's that's inappropriate ah
and i i go i'm sorry i like dark humor
she goes i like dark humor too and i was
like i don't think you do
and then i i said i'll prove it and i
did a holocaust joke and she went ah and
i went see and i got a huge laugh but
it's just like they all say i have a
great scent no one's ever said i don't
have a great sense of humor no one has
ever said that
no one's ever said it everyone thinks
they have a good sense of humor everyone
thinks they do we're professionals
mother teresa
gandhi everybody honestly like the good
age
yeah that's true i heard she was wild in
the sack by the way
but yeah
so it just annoyed me because i was like
you don't
you say you you want the you want the
cool credit for liking dark humor but
you don't you think you're funny but no
one in your life is telling not a lot of
people have someone in their life who
just is like hey you're not fun yeah
that's a good friend right there that is
but i mean but you lose a lot of friends
when you're not fun exactly you don't
have a really good friend to tell you
right they usually have friends who go
no you're great screw that guy he's a
dick because that takes less energy
exactly exactly it takes a lot of energy
to be like hey we need to talk like what
is it you're like
you just are just uh you're dreadful
yeah you're terrible no one wants to
have that talk that's like the thing
where you couldn't do that it'd be tough
it would be tough i couldn't do it i've
had you can do a side thing like you're
bad at this but to just go you to the
core are shitty you don't understand
humor or have concepts you don't have no
concept of what is funny you can't just
say that to a person right you can't but
there are people that don't understand
jokes that's true
some of them at our shows every weekend
yeah but uh and they think they do and i
think they're an expert but you know at
the same time uh it's been pretty good
lately on the road man that club
kentucky likes the comedy off broadway
that's a magical room magic room a lot
of history and you just i mean i feel
like an [ __ ] because you hear
kentucky and you go toothless uh hayseed
straw hat guy you know sipping out of a
moonshine out of a barrel with three x's
on it but
it's nice it's a nice it's a nice
beautiful rolling green hills and the
horses and the whiskey i love it yeah
kentucky freaking rules man i love it
george clooney from kentucky izzy
muhammad ali and diane sawyer damn i
think i'm right there peters
give that a goog it'd be great if you
just made up all three
uh that would be impressive
i went on uh jim and sam the other day
by the way they're back in studio it's
fun i got to go back i'm supposed to go
on tomorrow but i'm too [ __ ] i have
too much this week it's it's it's early
i'll give you that so early yeah but
they buy you breakfast now yeah but uh
[Music]
that's why i did it you're so easy like
you can't afford a [ __ ] egg salmon no
sheep bastard there was no food in my
house as a child it's it triggers me i
hear free breakfast i'll go to kuwait
um but either way
we did this whole rant about we got to
know me and jim got into this big fight
about music he's like i love this man i
was like white zombie get out of here
they say he likes he likes like hardcore
metal and dark edge and i was like what
about this band and i'd be like van
morrison he's like
then he went like dave matthews i was
like i do and then he went off on it and
then it was like this great back and
forth fighting fighting yelling you like
dave matthews well then that mike's cut
off and he's like that was great radio i
was like yeah i don't like dave matthews
i was just doing that he's like ah great
high five
yeah you just try to be entertaining you
know yeah then i got a bunch of messages
like thanks for defending dmv oh wow
you're a [ __ ] martyr to these people
yeah god damn it yeah man no there's
certain rooms though you just like
you do feel
you feel connected it's crazy like
there's a magic you talk about that like
yeah
richard bellzer did blow in this room
you just sense that i don't know but you
sensed that [ __ ] yeah oh yeah i know
we've made that comment before but
um wait what give me another weird band
you like
well no but i'm with you on the room
thing you can feel that like zany's in
chicago you're like oh i can feel that
jay leno was in here with a shitty
blazer an 84 you know
um
this is [ __ ] good oh yeah it's so
good i'm trying to like stop myself it's
tough do you have a peeve
i do actually hold up i got a bunch yeah
but give me one give me one because i
don't want to
all right well here's one and i know
i've made this to some degree before but
we've done a lot of episodes and we've
done patreon so i don't know about which
one i did on but this is i've two first
one i'm on a flight yesterday
guy sitting next to me is on a facetime
call
go on the ground he's on a facetime call
facebook no headphones oh so i'm just
like listening to his buddy and here's
the other thing you if you're if you're
in a public enclosed space and you're
not doing the public enclosed space
voice you're a monster
hey yeah i'm on i'm on a flight if
you're just like yeah so i told him suck
my dick you know
you're just doing that voice on a
[ __ ] flight there's other people
around woody is crazy because here's the
way to know if you're doing something
dickish
imagine everyone else on the plane doing
it
it would be chaos it would be chaos so
but for some reason you can do it
because we're all behaving we're all
decent human beings that's the test it
was crazy and then here's how weak i am
by the way we're in delta comfort and uh
he schmoozes this guy is reckless he
schmoozes the flight attendant into
giving us the first class snack boxes
so he but that so then i'm like wow he's
all right then we land the second we
land he's on facetime with no headphones
again i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
i bookended it with facetime
yeah that is a problem yeah i hate and
just for some reason facetime it's as
brutal as it is it's worse than a call
even a call i'm like all right this
guy's a douche but
it's like a phone call on speaker yes
and also i'm seeing your friend like
this is like a party you're throwing
yourself hey right yeah you're doing a
podcast he also took his shoes off on
the
flight that's a bold move your feet
sucks all right all right i don't you
know socks are stinky too though i know
everyone goes through
it to me it's very weird with like i
know you're like my feet swell up when i
fly cool still don't want to see him
yeah
yeah and also my socks if it's a woman
i'm okay with it i'm okay with a woman's
woman but women go
shoeless more women do like the sandals
more open toe men have gross feet they
really do it sorry
it is a hoof it's bad it's it's [ __ ]
stable with a jockey on your back you're
disgusting the knuckle hair like the toe
hair ah my toenails are yellow like the
sun i have talons i could catch salmon
with these [ __ ] feet they're
disgusting i'm with you it looks like a
velociraptor i'm trying to come in it's
bad news but yeah men's feet are
horrific i'm not one of these guys like
no man should ever wear flip-flops i get
it you want to wear a flip-flop but some
people can't even stay on the side i'm
going to go ahead and say no man should
ever wear flip-flops if you're going to
like a steam room a pool a sauna i'll
give it to you if you're going out in
public it's a bold [ __ ] movie that's
all i'm saying it is bull what about the
subway
i don't want any of that [ __ ] in this
look the subway is tough because it's
like what am i going to notice your
[ __ ] feet when a guy's dick is out to
my left like that's tough
i do here's my subway protocol
the one that bothers me more than
anything number one is obviously the
toenail clippings oh
you're a psycho you deserve the death
penalty yeah that's terrific you should
be shot in the face with a yeah like
taliban style yes then second i think um
they behead i guess whatever
but uh they could be put
the the stinky food on the subway that's
a problem that's a problem dude yeah
sticky food on a plane is bad too
because it's sealed at least the subway
opens every now and then true
yeah it's all bad it's all bad still
[ __ ] and it's bad for you
george garland what what do you what do
you got for me
this one's kind of specific i like the
specific ones okay you went specific
last week and i was into it all right
and this is another lady problem
sorry gals labia time but
that's a horrible kids show
we need we need a segment called the
labia corner
so uh this is i think i think only
specific to my dame is she'll go
i gotta go to the post office you wanna
go and i'm like no i don't go to the
post why would i that's a chore you're
doing errands but you you're trying to
invite me like it's some kind of fun
event quality time yes it's quality time
and i'm like no i don't go to the post
office or the dmv i don't want to go
anywhere with that [ __ ] and she's like
oh you don't want to hang out with me
i'm like
there we go now it's a hangout issue way
to spin it there sister she's a spinster
is what she is she spun that's a smart
women jiu-jitsu move it's like oh oh you
don't want to hang out with me i'm like
no i don't go to the post oh yeah you
want to go to the park you want to go to
the meadow you want to frolic you want
to run through the sprinklers i'm in i
would hit her back with i'd love to hang
out with you why don't you go there
another day and we'll watch a movie at
home
put it right back on it what are you
gonna do now that's good i'd love to
hang out take your dick out let's hang
out
this thing's
[Laughter]
that was the whole fox news post was
like uh chloe i'm not a pervert i'm
italian
i love when people use their culture
this uber driver stinks it's our culture
like all right well you still stink
we're celebrities now too
jake gyllenhaal he's like ah we don't
need a shower i saw that that's a weird
one i kind of dug it you dig it you're
not a big shower guys i think it's bad
for you well i don't think it's bad i
think we do it too much how often do you
shower
let's see
four times a week how much how often do
you sweat though like work out
maybe once
okay so
twice three times the lady but it's
summer too also winter i'm i'm stumped
down to three days a week winter yeah i
think that's acceptable how often do you
do you wash your hair and how i'm i'm
talking like soap versus wash hair too i
think hair wash is overrated i think we
do it too much i think it hurts your
hair yeah all the water shampoo can dish
shampoo rinse repeat that's just uh the
fat cats in washington telling you what
to do you don't really need to rinse and
repeat yeah but
i'd say hair wash
twice a week
wow yeah
you got sebum up there you got essential
oils
yeah i think we wash our hair too much
for sure but it's funny when like a
celebrity says this [ __ ] cause you know
like you know that he's like
he's got something that we don't have oh
yeah he's got some [ __ ] at home where
he's like yeah i don't need to shower
because i have these creams that are 900
a tube right right exactly
so that that's a different story but i
do think we uh we overdo it yeah uh but
yeah back to the lady yeah
she got me on that one and i but i held
my ground i was like i do not want to go
to the post office when i don't have to
and she was like all right fine whatever
and i think that's the key you got to uh
stand tall there like you getting hit at
a bar
what is is this a different drinker the
same
this is the same one okay jeez last
words let me know anything with campari
is good
you drink capari alone you want to kill
yourself but you drink it with something
it's amazing it's kind of like uh willem
dafoe
that's a callback
you pointed to me i thought you're going
to say me for a second oh no oh it was
your joke what what uh
but yeah that's my p i'm sticking to it
women
trying to yeah it is just saying like
hey will you come with me don't disguise
it as something don't don't try to serve
me [ __ ] and say it's a sandwich right
exactly
that's kind of like a southern
expression
don't try to serve me [ __ ] and say it's
a sandwich guys in kentucky one weekend
all of a sudden these foghorn
that would be a better show just a kid's
show where he's like shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ] [ __ ] rabbit
who's here who's [ __ ] lego he was the
big rooster and uh
my last word is a woman should not have
the right to choose
i mean of course
post office activities as such oh yeah
by the way cuomo
uh
speaking of face time good who had more
face time than cuomo huh he loved
touching a face it's such a weird move
yeah that's where i'm like maybe the
italian culture maybe there is some
truth to it but he also got off on power
and [ __ ]
like that dude it's it's funny how much
they're like chris cuomo advising him
and i'm like it's his brother like what
do you expect like
like yeah it's [ __ ] up and yeah it's
not ethical but you're just kind of like
what's what's he gonna do like oh my
brother's calling me ignored right
wouldn't he shittier if he didn't do
that if he's like i've got a
yeah i had a my that was my angle was
they should do a podcast together and
chris never speaks
[Laughter]
dude it's uh
it's weird it's kind of like
it's the end of the guy's career
probably i mean what's he gonna do now
yeah i think podcast is the only route
or stand-up he can do like a my name is
earl type show where he knocks on all
the women's doors i mean like let's sit
down and talk about it right right yeah
there's not much left it's a bummer and
they had a his dad
had a hell of a powerhouse yeah it was
he was the killer he was like the young
killer that you brought in i mean it's
tough when you're known as the [ __ ]
right
but i think you can't get too big in
america like he was that got cuomo
sexual he won an emmy
i mean every girl was like cuomo i'm in
a cuomo where is this coming from
mullany the girls that he touched yeah
that's true not every girl they weren't
as vocal until later but uh yeah like he
got big and then taken down but i also
think it's like there's truth to that
where like oh you know obviously
people were talking about like maybe
he'll swoop in and run instead of biden
like there was talk like that how big he
was getting he should be the president
and now it's like man he would be
democratic trump
that's exactly who he'd be yeah you know
i mean
i don't know he definitely
you're right he got too big but i think
he was just
probably hell to work for i think he
treated people like [ __ ] really i don't
you think i don't know anything about
him really i mean if you're
how many of these aides
are gonna like speak out yeah
you know that's the problem is they the
sheer numbers it's like what is it up to
nine
you know nine ten women so you're kind
of like
i think that's right scenario he's a
shitty person right right i think he's
gotten kind of gotten his way so long
you know with dad being so high up sure
and then money and
the nipple rings
weird man yeah how many politicians have
nipple rings it's gotta be just him and
fdr i mean
wiener had clamps but i don't think he
had the right
but now what we got the new the new
governor
coastal coast
yeah what's your name what's your name
look
so i'm gonna she's got an interesting
last name i think it might be polish
i don't know i can't remember it but uh
i didn't know a governor did anything
until cuomo came on the scene thank you
what do you got here is this in the
ground it looks like the ground
you jealous or what
i am but this is really good it's a hell
of a last word negroni is
i would say like top five cocktails ever
wow is that is that too bold of
statement or what
what are your top five cocktails ever
my top five yeah yeah my number one is a
really nicely made super super iced cold
filthy dirty martini i'm with can we do
one of those next episode 100 all right
i'm a vodka guy though me too all right
let's do it kettle one gregoo
i honestly like vodka's vodka you know
as long as it's not like bottom shelf
okay but kettle's great i like kettles
nice i also like potato vodkas so like
uh
the polish potato vodkas like you know
chopin belvedere things like that it's a
little insensitive to the irish with the
famine but i get it i love it all right
so that's number one give me number yeah
i'm that's the top five number two uh
manhattan that's my number one whoa
absolutely i'm waiting for the for
colder months for you for the manhattan
i already got that lined up uh and then
number three would be like negroni or
old-fashioned old-fashioned is in the
top five for sure interesting
okay good list
and what else we got i think i got one
more and um
you know besides that i would do
something like uh like something like
offbeat like uh you know like a corp
survivor number two is really good what
the hell is that well we'll do that
later don't worry corp survivor man
it's a hangover cocktail that's all
booze but you don't know it's all booze
really yeah it's really good wow
so i think we do martini next episode
and we do a corp survivor the episode
after that is that hell yeah deal all
right i'm excited what's that old joke
uh my parents
ah i i don't tell my parents i was a
necrophiliac oh i'm gonna butcher it i
can never remember a joke hold on let me
think of it [ __ ] what do you got mad on
the name the lady kathy something
cathy who pokel oh kathy hokel what do
you got a wendy's uh drive through here
that
hey we might be drunk is brought to you
by honey
you gotta love honey i mean come on you
shop online we all do it you buy shoes
you buy groceries you buy toilet paper
and we've all seen that empty promo code
thing just taunting you and you're like
oh i've only had a promo code i'd get
half off or a percentage something but i
never have one who has that you go to
some shoe brand you're like ah i could
get i could get a real discount here but
i never have it i always wonder who does
well now honey is the free browser
extension that scours the internet for
discount codes when you're ready to
check out honey automatically applies
the best one instant savings honey has
found its customers over 2 billion clams
in savings supported by over 30 000
stores online buy anything from tech
gaming beer wine you name it
i i saved on uh some sweet kicks
thanks to honey put that coat in
got a discount shoes are expensive get a
break tell them how to do it fatty
if you don't have honey
uh you could be straight up missing out
on free savings it's literally free
installs in just a few seconds save some
dough and support this podcast get honey
for free at joinhoney.com
drunk that's join honey dot com slash
drunk and get that honey baby yeah
what uh so we got uh all right can i
give you another peeve
please i had an issue with all right
so
i had an issue with you know sending my
girlfriend i i made a bit of a mistake
so i sent her i'm fl i'm sorry flowers
pro flowers all right oh i love pro
flowers i don't uh oh here we go and
i'll tell you what these people tell you
they're only the go-to because they come
up first on google that's 100 there's
one eight hundred five eight hundred
it's not the first time they [ __ ] me
ah
um but yeah the
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
aids
um so
what were we saying
oh uh flowers flowers yes so i sent her
i'm sorry flowers they don't deliver
them all right they mess it up they
deliver it but they're like no one's in
the office and i'm like well you got to
make them sure they're there that day
because she's on the road that's how i'm
sending them
they were like all right absolutely it's
going to be there that day they don't
send it and it's like the whole thing
where they're like the florist is closed
i'm like okay so you got you're
admitting that you're like a second hand
you know right whatever [ __ ]
middleman company exactly whatever so
then um
i call the next day and they're like
we're definitely going to come the next
day i'm like she's leaving in like a day
yeah
they don't and it's one of those things
where like i it's [ __ ] up because i'm
furious but i'm also like i'm set the
guy keeps saying i'm sorry and i won't
accept it yeah and i'm sending i'm sorry
flowers
this is a bit it might be yeah but i'm
like i'm i'm like he was like he was
like i'm sorry i'm sorry i was like
that's not good enough i'm like holy
[ __ ] i'm her ah you're like you got to
send me flowers now you're [ __ ] up
with the flowers i've turned into the
woman yeah wow well he keeps [ __ ] up
we never yeah i was like he's me he's a
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] did she get him
no we didn't
i know i got refunded and see this the
problem is the lady
sorry ladies i'm calling you all one
unit
you don't know the hell it is to get
flowers you really don't every guy on
the day before valentine's day is
scrambling like
they got to get there by this time this
is the building she works at this office
it's a nightmare and then they never
come on time you got to redo it blah
blah blah and then they finally get them
when it's too late and they're like
thanks and you're like oh i went through
hell it's hot these holidays have an
incredibly high they give women
incredibly high expectations and they're
not that high look we should be able to
meet them at the same time like
if you don't meet them you're just in
the doghouse yeah exactly exactly and
you're relying on this dude who doesn't
know you or give a [ __ ] about you he's
in [ __ ] mumbai exactly gives a [ __ ]
about me yeah he's like i'd kill for a
woman you know i got a lady carrying a
jug over here
whatever that whatever happens over
there but you know
this is worse than the [ __ ] labia
segment
labia time
i love it yeah but that is a [ __ ] it
was a [ __ ] and never got him see
because i i used to open for a woman and
she would be like look i want to level
with you the only reason women like
flowers is because you gotta [ __ ] get
off your ass go to a website pull out a
credit card we like that you did
something we like that you put some
effort in and i'm like okay so if i
actually plucked the flowers you
wouldn't she's like no no that's no good
i want you to pay i want you to sting
well plucking the flowers is probably i
think it's a gesture i think it's just
like you [ __ ] put work in yeah but if
we pluck them they look like [ __ ] let's
be honest so like right they like the
presentation they like that it's
i don't know do women even give a [ __ ]
about flowers i think they do i think
they they try to come off oh i'm a
feminist i don't care i'm i'm empowered
now you like flowers i'm sorry you like
the effort you like the thought it's all
thought
yeah you know i mean look at every movie
you got to kill the dragon to save the
lady in the tower
if you didn't have to kill the dragon
she'd be like so he just showed up
the dragon was dead
are you comparing slaying a dragon to
logging onto proflowers.com the dragon's
easier because there's no
[ __ ] expiration date and qr code and
all that the dragon's cut and dry
i don't know i hate the credit card
system it's not good this this segment's
dragging
no i think uh the dragon is uh
but i'll just say it's taught it's it's
it's it's ingrained in us like
jump a big hump to get to the lady yeah
and if you want to get a big hump yeah
right it's no it's a work it don't tell
you
oh yeah you give your girl your mom's
ring i think they're kind of like
i want you to buy a ring
yeah but they but that's a good one
because they can't say [ __ ] i know it's
a family it's a family tradition yeah
that's kind of fun my mom is the least i
hope she never hears this she's the
least aware woman on the planet she'll
be like do you want to go to the nursery
the plant nursery with me at 7am
tomorrow and i'm like why would i ever
want to do that like i don't want to go
meet
richard pryor at 7 00 am like what are
you crazy richard pryor i would i would
but i'm just saying like
i don't even have i've never shown any
interest in plants or botany or anything
or a greenhouse and you want me to go at
7 am on a set what are you insane like
you want to
take her by the shoulders and shake her
but
she'll be like do you think do you think
your lady would love this
ornament from my great-grandmother i'm
like yeah you know she might but really
she's gonna pretend to care and like it
i don't know it's just my mom is is
tough in that way what uh give me a good
rash all right here's your wreck
sorry i went i went to full therapy
there i liked it
i think you've seen it i don't know if
you've seen it there bear
beer
jew but
i
saw this it changed my life the water
works the whole thing val
i haven't seen it yet i'm gonna watch it
this week i almost watched it last night
my god is it touching and real
this son of a [ __ ] filmed his whole
life from when he was five he had a
video camera home movies
i mean the the tear jerking in this it's
unbelievable and it's all just
his life like the the editing is
unbelievable they put it all together in
a perfect narrative and it gets to him
to this day and the [ __ ] he went through
and the struggle and he's got so much
integrity he's a real artist i really am
a big fan of al kilmer for sure i always
thought about he's an actor or whatever
but now after this i'm like he's one of
my favorite guys you know in tombstone
when he's got the tuberculosis he's
laying in the bed he's on a bed of ice
because he wanted to look he wanted to
know what it felt like to be that cold
damn like he went all in and all these
movies were like you're the hot guy
you're this you're batman or what he was
like all right great be back it wasn't
his fault that that batman sucks
that was a hot crowd that was that hot
cast rather i mean yeah you had tommy
lee jones his two-face you would you had
jimmy
and like in theory it could have been
like that kind of fun damn that's right
nicole kidman so joel schumacher
director who did the lost boys and all
these other huge movies so he's like i
grew up with batman of course i want to
be batman he was in africa doing like a
safari when he got the call
and he was in a bat cave i don't want to
give too much away but it's it's
fascinating and the trauma this guy went
through and the death this kiss bang
bang is like one of my favorite movies
of all time great movie great comedy but
he got labeled as difficult
like they show him on oprah and she's
like i heard you're difficult to work
with he's like i just want to be an
actor i feel like i'm so disappointed
with these roles in hollywood
he was the youngest person ever accepted
to juilliard wow yeah so
interesting guy
real actor real method the whole thing
and uh
i mean it's such good footage he got
bumped by kevin bacon
you know like a school or a broadway
show and then he's like all right i'm
second to kevin bacon this guy's a star
and then sean penn bumps him and he's
like god and that's when he's like oh
now i see what hollywood so it's all
about who's the it guy
you know and it's all about the industry
and they don't give a [ __ ] i mean it's
really and it it it hits home damn
check it out watching with the lady i'm
a big fan yeah i will um
yeah he's he's great man he's a great
actor great and he's like
he's always been
good at like any time like it's crazy
top secret he's [ __ ] hilarious that's
his first movie yeah and then you put
like kiss kiss bang bang is hilarious
and then you just had he was looking at
action movies and stuff but
he yeah that ponytail dude i know i know
that that's one of his better roles i
think because he's like i got to work
with de niro and pacino and he's so
excited and then his hero was brando and
then he got to work with him on island
dr moreau which was a [ __ ] show a train
wreck yeah i mean that
brando is so
what a character man but what a fall i
mean that guy he really
oh my god he went nuts and like he was
he you ever seen that clip of him
throwing up
since the 50s dude oh no i'm not saying
but it's like that guy was famous for
decades you know yeah but he he kind of
he well nuts and then he kind of ate
himself to death but that scene of him
on i think he's on larry king he's just
like n word this and the jews run the
media to apologize to the jewish
coalition but he loved jews too that was
the other thing is like brando's like
studied under jews for acting i mean he
like had so much love for jews and i
think he was just nice man he was nuts
yeah i mean i i don't think he had a
racist bone his body i mean he was all
about like i mean you see what he did at
the native american the oscars i mean i
think brando was like kind of ahead of
his time a little bit pretty crazy i
mean yeah holy [ __ ] i mean it is funny
that he did that in like the 70s and
then and they were like the indians
should be a team yeah that [ __ ] red
face
no uh brando man i i think of like that
dude's range is [ __ ] stupid he's the
best he's probably one of the best of
all time i mean
i think on the waterfront a top 20 movie
yeah
could have been a contender yeah yeah
[ __ ] masterful that is a great script
it's beautiful
a street car he's incredible in you get
guys and dolls yeah they call you
ladylock it's [ __ ] incredible i mean
the godfather get out of here godfather
apocalypse now yes yes
uh that [ __ ] you ever heard that
old norm joke about about brando he goes
uh
marlon brando
made some
you know derogatory marks towards jewish
people and he had to apologize to the
the jews in hollywood and they accepted
the apology and allowed him to work
again
that's not a total joke it's [ __ ]
hilarious that was a weekend update norm
damn that you can't could you get away
with that one today i don't think so i
don't think i mean he had 20 minutes on
oj killing his wife yeah but he got
fired over he got fired over it yeah
damn
um he's the guy like does he have money
i was wondering i guess he does the road
are you kidding me i never know who's
got money and who's [ __ ] kidding me i
can't tell i don't think he's i don't
think he's loaded
i think he's loaded all right all right
think about how many sitcoms he's been
on over the years how many shows he's
been on over the years norma's got money
all right i worry about guys like him i
wouldn't worry i would worry about like
there's a lot of people in la i'd worry
about before norm i'll put it that way
all right have you driven under an
overpass good point good point yeah
that's true la's uh la's in trouble but
i'm you know i don't know if that guy
under the overpass has got a great uh
album yeah no he's i think norm's doing
all right all right just checking he's
got a son
he's i think he's okay okay still eating
cereal you want to be like come on man
you can't you can't drive eat cereal i
can't drive i live in an apartment i
live in an apartment all right all right
i feel attacked right now no i know
you're doing fine though you got a nice
lady you got the mom around you you're
you're doing okay i'm all right yeah
yeah i'm i'm good i'm happy uh-oh
that's no
that's
that's saying his net worth is 52.5
million that's but that's bananas those
are all like you look you up it's gonna
be like 20 something yeah those are all
out of whack but i appreciate them
but i think that helps with the ladies
that would be a good tinder profile you
know if you just wrote my net worth yeah
you'll attract some real quality women
with that with that profile well you
know when you're on dinner you're not
trying to you know bring somebody home
to mom yeah fair enough what uh
what else should we tell you
what do you got on a wreck do you have a
wreck yeah i do did i do i didn't do
this last week did i met uh to die for
no it's on hulu it's a gus van sant
movie i love you guys i've seen this
movie there's a third time i watched it
so it's uh to die for it's starring
nicole kidman
young young joaquin phoenix and kate uh
phoenix and casey affleck
and uh matt dillon's in it wow what a
cast great cat wayne knight from
seinfeld oh
he's great is it 95
90s around then yeah it's you know what
the tone of it is it's written by buck
henry who's also in it who wrote the
graduate who's a genius yeah buck henry
is a [ __ ] american genius so
uh
it's incredible it's right it's the tone
if you like the movie election you'll
like this i love elections it's that
tone okay it's like it's a dark as hell
comedy
that is like the way election is a gold
standard satire this is the same all
right
wow really yeah yeah nicole kim is
incredible in it i think it's the second
straight week i've wrecked the nicole
kidman thing but that was last week on
the undoing oh yeah but i'll tell you
this movie is like so i laughed out loud
so many times it's just about a deranged
person who wants fame more than anything
and holy [ __ ] did it make me think of a
lot of people we know
you got that right it's great young
joaquin's incredible he's amazing it's
it's a great uh
oh uh what's your elena douglas is great
enough oh she's always fun she's always
it's just a great
i love gusman sam i do too and and it's
cool because i used to work at
blockbuster and i would see that box to
die and i was like oh there's going to
be some kind of shoes like porno or kind
of like
nc 17 but it's it's actually type of
movie you would have rented with a kid
and you're just like fast forwarding for
the sex scene yeah and then you're like
this is it
it's just really sharp satire right
right i had that with time cop a lot of
fast forwarding oh my god
mia mia whatever mia sarah the chick
from ferris bueller i never saw it ah i
never saw time van damme uh i feel like
an action romp yeah
he goes to the future and has to fight
himself it's a lot of fun
i highly recommend to die for it's on
hulu if you have hulu and uh
it's like
it's really [ __ ] funny all right yeah
that's a great wreck really funny nice
little throwback yeah it's weird man the
90s are like classic now
isn't that weird it's [ __ ] bananas
and i i just gotta get used to it and
get over it
isn't that weird man yeah yeah i mean
you see kids
kids ironically wearing a nirvana shirt
i'm like oh [ __ ]
i went you know to a nirvana show not
really i actually didn't but yeah i was
like
i want to see lip biscuit and i regret
it you saw when biscuits my friend had
an extra ticket i'd never been to a
concert he's like you never been to a
concert i'm like no except for jazz and
blues and [ __ ] in new orleans but
we went it was i hated it it was all
they had a couple songs though
not not for me i hate the hat the
backwards
the the
like fake faux wrap is it wrap is it
metal what are we doing here is it ramp
is it punk is it yeah what is it not
into it and it was all that angry [ __ ]
like give me something to break i'm like
i'm not that angry
okay i'm hanging out i'm 11. great if
they start rioting just destroying the
set he's like no not this yeah please
yeah yeah exactly yeah just one of those
days i'm like you don't want to wake up
yeah everything is [ __ ] everything
sucks i'm not here just like hey this
was not exactly uh inspired lyrics no
i feel like i have more angst now you
know you always said with the angsty
teenager i'm like no i was cruising on
the team
you're less angry than you you you have
less angst uh
i think you're more together now than
when i met you oh really yeah all right
i'll take that you've gone to therapy
you've you've become a better person i
think yeah you're more i i think i don't
know i mean i think i'm i'm not saying
about a good or bad person i'm just
saying like you know like [ __ ] you mom i
never had that growing up i like my mom
i think you have you had more of it when
i met you than you do now
really do some anger when i met you you
think yeah i think we both did oh when
you're a young comic you just have some
[ __ ] anger man there's like like the
business is still [ __ ] but i think
that we had less control back then ah
good point good point we were just
younger we just didn't understand
like we i think we more look i'm still
lost i think we had less of an
understanding on on life you know
definitely definitely yeah okay all
right well hey that's that's one to grow
on or what do you call it
that's a good note to end on or wait
what about a bit we gotta do best
i got one for you all right
so
i think i brought this up last week i
decided to try it a bit i think there's
something here about
so i told my dad i can't ride a bike
you know and he was like he was like
making fun of me about it he was like
you can't he's like you can't ride a
bike that's hilarious no you're my dad
yeah you know what i mean like so i was
like it's kind of like if you're it's
like if your girl it's like if your
girlfriend or wife was like man you
never get [ __ ]
something like that there's someone
there right yeah yeah that's good
man if only there's someone who could
have done something about this
right that's great it's a great twist
some in there right yeah good good
perfect comparison we can do that on the
patreon if you haven't signed up for a
patreon it's patreon.com we might be
drunk pod mark wants to take me bike
riding in central park i'm terrified i
will get the bike i'll get a city bike
we'll get sal accused we'll get peters
out there maybe we'll get drunk who
knows and uh no training wheels i'm
gonna hold the back i'm gonna dress like
a dad wear a cardigan have a pipe i hope
you have like a hat with a propeller on
it
i have a helmet i'll be wearing all
right perfect and we'll do the grass and
then we'll eventually get you going on
the sidewalk and you'll never forget it
i'm i'm nervous it's like riding a bike
it's going to be great
what do you got you want to have a bike
skill i feel bad that you're walking by
city bikes and bikers all day going i
can't do that that's going to hit the
psyche a little
yeah probably it doesn't no i mean like
it would if it was like necessary for
living in this city like if i if i was
you're acting like i was in a wheelchair
and i saw people walking i'm i can walk
i can take the subway i can take a cab
i'm not i i can still get around well
let's say you go to atlantic city with
your lady and yeah that's the honeymoon
destination
[Laughter]
all right you go to martha's vineyard or
nantucket and she goes we got the whole
day off let's let's let's go bike riding
on she knows me she knows why would she
do that why would she go let's do
something that you can't do wow does she
know you can't because i didn't know you
couldn't ride a bike until two days ago
yeah she knows because she was terrified
when i left la and was like i'll ride
bikes during the pandemics like please
don't
i don't
yeah no i just
absolutely not all right all right well
i'm going to show you it's it's it's
super easy you're an athletic guy you
play basketball
well you swim i swim and i shoot baskets
okay that's that's a tough thing that's
enough it's enough that's all i need
it's just getting my cardio enough
up that if i get the delta variant i
won't die
that's a good health barometer right
there
uh all right how about this for a bit
hit me so these drinks by the way holy
[ __ ] dan i know i'm just trying to be
[ __ ] up it's a black out here one more
we got a picture i can't i have i have a
thing i have to do after this that i
cannot be i have to ride a bike
so
what do you got
all right so um
you know
got engaged the girlfriend's always got
to post about the engagement i want some
engagement posts post post
why do i have to post this is our thing
who cares about it i saw another post
yeah yeah tell me about it
so
so i'm like why why this is between us
it's the you know
matrimony bond or whatever and she's
like just post about it means a lot to
me it's a special thing for me and i'm
like i hear that i get that okay i i
agree and i go well we had a threesome
once so i'm gonna post about that did
you yeah and she's like well i don't
know about that i'm like well that was
special to me
and she's like yeah but this is a bond
between two people i'm like that was a
bond between three
three two that's a great bit yeah
i'm sure that's already hidden i tried
it once and it it did okay but i can't
find my footing yet but that's that was
between three is is a great line oh you
like okay okay did you try that line yet
yeah yeah that that's the only laugh it
got but i was you know it was
freewheeling
in this setup it's tough because it's
like well obviously you share a wedding
photo
and not of course
like obviously there's that flawing at
the gate but like the the the bond
between three line is killer yeah she's
like that's but the wedding like i
dreamed about as a kid i'm like
i dreamed about this as a kid you know
and then i do a whole thing where like a
wedding i told my friends about this
well i told my friends about this yeah
oh that's good
and a wedding for a girl is like a
threesome for a guy because you you
envision them the same way who are we
gonna invite where are we going to do it
that's good how much it's going to cost
[Laughter]
so it needs some money
that didn't do great but uh the other
part did how much is going to cost i
thought that was going to hit two and it
didn't that's comedy how many times you
tried it once i get another shot oh yeah
also uh yeah
she hates the bit but uh i'm also like
hey we're talking about the engagement
you wanted more exposure yeah
so so there could be something about
like you know the three and look i'll be
honest the threesome wasn't all as
planned you know it was the same as my
wedding night
no
tell me about my best man i was going to
say
that
no
i think like um
wedding yeah i was trying to avoid uh
something about i didn't eat the fish
the fish but i'm trying to avoid that
that part but yeah yeah it's so there's
got to be more there you know like my
mom loved it you know
yeah something like that
um that picture i guess
and like and she's right because uh
we don't have any pictures in the
three-way but we've got some great video
oh that's good
yeah that's good
that's something yeah that's funny
you know i put that on instagram yeah
they blocked it
it is weird that like
it's it's very
it's way the wedding shows
that to the woman that you're serious
the three-way shows the man that she is
yeah exactly exactly like how come
ladies get their thing but we can't have
our thing well you did get your thing
well i mean like publicly
if you're not really going to publish
i think that's the the bit is is you
just keep going with the three-way
versus the way right right you've got
the angles i think the cost is funny i
think uh
i think you planning the three-way the
way a woman would plan
would plan the like we were just like uh
we hire a plan what do we do for the
food yeah
yeah
exactly
that's good
what if there's a joke in like i object
or some that guy in there or the priest
yeah there's a lot here there's a lot to
play with because weddings are so big
because there's a lot of angles to go
down
damn i can't believe you had a three-way
i i actually didn't i made that up oh
really yeah but it's for the good of the
bit that's yeah that's i was going to be
like damn i [ __ ] i ran a buyer she
was like yeah whatever oh to do on stage
yeah yeah you know like can i say we had
a three-way she's like ah you're a comic
yeah yeah it's all for the joke that's
what people don't get about jokes it's
all mechanics well i some of it a lot of
it's true is the truth i mean
or like you know if it's a story it's
definitely true i think it there may be
parts that you like i've had bits where
like i end on and i'm like well that
ending is like a little doctored yeah
but like
it's it always comes from a real place
in some way yes yes
the real place in this bit is like well
if we had a threesome i'd want to
tell people exactly you know and you
want to tell me about your thing yeah
you know but i just think it's weird
when people were like i do a school
shooting joke
you know kids when i was growing up kids
yelled shotgun now kids yell that in the
classroom and people like how dare you
make a joke about school shoot i'm like
it's just the shotgun shotgun like
that's all i saw there i was like that's
a bit that could be something you
connected something connected
in your mind to make a a fun dark joke
yeah
promoting you're mocking your age versus
this age i mean that's that's it i got i
got a i got a homonym or a homophone
about mass shootings now my act right
now it's like you know i feel like i had
in the last one too but now it's a more
personal bed it's about me like teasing
a kid and totally threatening to shoot
up to school and it becomes a whole
story
you know yeah and i feel [ __ ] guilty
about it so that's why i'm talking about
it but we're cool i mean he comes to
shows now oh yeah yeah but i mean it's
one of those things we were like oh [ __ ]
it's like it turned into a bit well i
feel guilty right that's why i made it a
bit i was like it's like my confession
yes you know oh interesting interesting
well we didn't i mean at least i didn't
grow up with
school shootings really i actually
columbine was i was in ninth grade so
maybe i did i mean i still remember the
rock bit like we didn't have any friends
there were six of you [ __ ]
we don't have six friends that's three
on three with a half court that's a
great [ __ ] great [ __ ] he opened with
that too that's a [ __ ] amazing
mafia oh yeah that was great yeah yeah i
mean you know i see white kids come on
now i jump off the elevator
i mean that was uh
yeah that was legendary that was
legendary
it is
i am scared of young white boys that was
the opening
ever being like oh my god he's going in
he's going right to columbine it was so
good yeah i definitely wasn't scared of
school shootings when i was in school
yeah now kids it's one of the things
where like kids have to think about that
well you never crazy that's an insult
now like we were like fat ugly gay and
they're like
school shooter like that's an insult now
like how many roasts have you seen where
they go joe list looks like a school
shooter like it's a go-to
glasses nerd look school shooter joke
yeah that's new not new but newish isn't
that crazy that's crazy kids have to
worry about
i mean that's the thing is like we all
saw guns in high school i grew up in
manhattan and i saw a gun so it's like i
damn no i damn sure we'll know you
suburban kids saw them right right you
know like
that's crazy they usually that's
something you have to think about that's
stress on a kid man that's great yeah
i'd have been in my last special like
man now getting held back is a real
threat that was my angle
like you you want to go to summer school
please i've already done two tours of
freshman year that was the gym outdoors
yeah that was that was a bit i had on on
school shooting but i remember that but
they [ __ ]
that's a real thing man
well i mean i feel like the inner city
schools kind of had a metal detector
thing going on but then when it hit like
white i love when a club has metal
detectors i do too i love metal
detectors i love them but it's not great
with my hip
my fake hip but no um but the same hip
that had a three-way
it wasn't easy
to really
tighten those bolts but i just think
it was big but it's funny how like black
comics always like when it hits white
people that's when it becomes a story
it's true it's so true when it hits the
sandy hook or columbine it's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] about uh about chicago i mean
that's that's the truth i mean like
there's some such so many shootings in
chicago more than iraq yeah died in
jakarta it's great it's all the whole
thing's crazy but then it's weird cause
like i have black friends who are like
don't ever bring up the chicago thing
white people will always do that they
always do it it's true very well it is
true so do we bring it up too much or do
we not talk about it enough it's it's a
tough line there for sure
for sure no it's true
i mean i don't know
guns are just i i'm just not a gun guy
they'd scare the [ __ ] out of me i'm not
although you know i know some of you are
listening like well you're not a bike or
a car guy either sam so shut the [ __ ] up
i could teach you how to shoot a gun
we'll go to central park we'll do a
patreon
well i was in oklahoma i was just an okc
and uh liz who runs a club there who
she's great oh yeah she was like let's
go shooting tomorrow and i was like i'm
in but i'm [ __ ] i was too tired
but i was like i would love to go
shooting my friend you know chris allen
he was in the military he's a big gun
guy and he took me
in uh i think we were in dayton and we
went to the gun
range too into sopranos he would scare
me i feel like he would make a joke like
you big mouth [ __ ] right but the thing
with guns is just so real like you're
like bam bam you feel that pop and the
kick back and you're like whoa this is
wild and you can turn it sideways and
you can end the life it's a lot of
responsibility
i'm not a big gun guy either but they
scare me yeah
i'm just uh it's too intense i don't
like anything that definite i don't like
a balcony i don't like a [ __ ] balcony
i don't like anything that that could be
lead to permanence yeah
i don't like a wedding ring
hey nobody does
but you're right i i'm with you with the
definite we like lights we like in and
out we do the road you're in kentucky
you're out of context we're cowboys man
we're [ __ ] we're literally blowing up
on a horse uh they like guns yeah well
they like guns well we're rambling we're
ramblers i love it we're not really
cowboys no i mean we did [ __ ] that one
time but uh other than that i can't quit
you
that was a good movie great movie that's
another appreciated movie great movie
it's i heard mark wahlberg turned down
the gyllenhaal part oh big mistake but
then he but then he's playing do you see
the trailer for his new movie where he
plays a dad where his gay son kills
himself like that's a more mark wahlberg
role
he's just like i [ __ ] failed you as a
father oh no i haven't seen that trailer
it's rough man he's a punch line
he's a good actor no he's not bad he's
not bad boogie nights is great boogie
nights is amazing but uh i wonder if
gyllenhaal is like damn i [ __ ] a dead
guy
yeah the guy [ __ ] is dead yeah it was
acting though that's true
that's true i think i think i think his
wife was probably more like i [ __ ] the
dead guy
was he married
he was like as strange i think from
michelle williams wasn't it didn't they
have a kid together she's a hell of an
actress she's great heath ledger old man
killer actor what a what a way to go out
broke back and and the dark knight
is how you go out
that's kind of legend
could you give me two more different
roles yeah
good point than a gay badass cowboy
and the joker yeah
speaking of val
his i don't want to give too much away
but his wife leaves him because he's
always like obsessed with his roles so
she bails
so there's a price to pay for art is he
is he together with someone now
i don't think so well then also the
throat thing kicked in that's tough yeah
poor guy i know he's such a sweet guy i
mean you gotta watch somebody tweeted
about bargati's album years ago do you
remember that no he tweeted about nate
bargots he's out and being like what a
wonderful comedian or something like
that you're like oh i love that guy well
yeah he's he's all heart i mean he's
integrity he's sweet he's nice he's got
two great kids the kid narrates the
whole thing because he can't talk
oh my god could you imagine not being
able to talk it's we we take it for
granted we do podcasts we do stand up
this is everything the voice poor guy
yeah will we ever recover no i don't
think so
[ __ ] i know i know that this is all
wrapped up in the plot you gotta you
gotta see it i mean take a night off and
really turn the lights out get a popcorn
i'm at the cellar later but i'll
probably i'll probably watch it later
watch it after damn
it you do you could use a little pain in
your life
but we got to wrap this thing up
give some road shoutouts man i'm i'm in
portland oregon uh royal oak michigan
boston i laugh boston uh atlanta georgia
millersville pennsylvania philadelphia
uh [ __ ] uh
moon tower in austin i think it's sold
out though i got uh what else [ __ ] man
i'm everywhere i'm [ __ ] everywhere
you're everywhere you're on the road and
you're grinding it that's what it's all
about building cameras.com shows for
tickets i'm just checking my miss oh
yeah saint louis
uh helium and that's sorry they got a
new manager finally indie helium
good room springfield missouri man i'm
really hitting up missouri i'm i'm
trying to get covered at this point
chicago the den
denver comedy works
[ __ ] cobbs in san francisco stand up
live we got great gigs coming up i can't
wait
so it's it's going to be great and uh
yeah [ __ ] it's going to great gig's
coming up samerworld.com shows
see you there man careful in sf i hear
it's uh wild west out there is this
that's what i hear well it's november so
okay okay hopefully it's better by then
i i'm sure it won't be but
who knows hopefully it's better when flu
season starts uh
oh yeah flu season i forgot about that
i'm at the arlington improv appleton
wisconsin skyline funny bone albany west
palm beach improv comedy connection in
providence company on state and
madison probably on state the goat
nashville rochester
richmond oh greg
portland boston atlanta buckhead theater
trying my theater shop we'll see what
happens
and uh yeah get on the patreon you're
missing out we're doing we're going to
unbox these [ __ ] on a patreon
see what's in them could be sars could
be a bomb
anthrax
covet delta lambda who knows
come on by we go we'll read your emails
pex we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
email us uh
patreon.com we might be drunk pod we're
growing pretty quickly leave us a nice
review and fat cat we'll be sitting
right here pretty soon we got you we've
got a sweet design you guys are gonna
[ __ ] jizz good looking bottles
in your own hand in a hotel room
i told you that in confidence this is
terrible
all right thanks guys
[Music]
you